okay guys so this is uh this is a big
one for me this is something that
emerged
for me today i was um among friends
feeling really good feeling really
incongruent
with these people and what came to mind
immediately was why
do i feel such harmony in this moment
why do i feel such attunement
with all of these individuals why do i
feel so loose and free
and comfortable and of course the firs
the first conclusion was man i'm really
a social
anxiety kind of person like i'm
not this comfortable most of the time i
don't like most people that i come
across i have compassion i'm nice i'm
kind but i'm not
really at ease with most people that i
come across i'm not really
engaged with most people that i come
across because it turns out my friends
that
finding people you resonate with finding
people you have emotional attunement
with finding people you have what's
known as emotional
synchrony with is actually really rare
and we tend to instead lose our our
worrying about pleasing those we don't
really get along with social pressures
create this kind of anxiety where we
find ourselves trapped in
in people-pleasing and babysitting uh
social psychodynamics you know all these
kinds of high school vibes where it's
just like well you know this person's
there and they're going to bring that
prayer i don't really like that person
but okay be nice let's just go along to
get along and what happens is
our our inner lives the mental content
of our social lives becomes compromised
becomes an act
in and of compromise and what happens is
that's
really limiting because you're not
really with your playmates you're not
really with your tribe you're not really
with your crew
and i guess what i'm saying is it's okay
to be a bit more discriminating about
the people you choose to spend your
time with and i'm not saying don't be
challenged then i'm not saying
don't hang out with interesting people
that have different and diverse
viewpoints don't just
hang out with people that are just like
you but certainly find
the others you know certainly find your
tribe certainly be
on the lookout for emotional attunement
and emotional
synchrony what is desired is people you
can connect with
so that you can have shared mental
experiences inter-subjective
experiences that's what i live for to be
in tune with people to be on the same
page as people the effortless effort
of getting along with somebody of
actually having
fun and and it's sad actually
how precious little time we give
to actually having fun to actually
hanging out with people we
genuinely like and and perhaps this is
just
a rant on like reclaiming stewardship of
your internal life
and of your social life stop the people
pleasing stop the baby sitting stop the
guilt and and and stop the
the the the the transactional and
superficial
pull uh towards situations that don't
nourish you and in which you can play
not so that's so then ultimately that's
what i'm
inviting you into instead is is play
find people you can
play with find your playmates find your
tribe
find your band find those spaces of
inter-subjective and emotional synchrony
and attunement
where you're having a shared experience
it's like a scene
in a play and all the actors are
participating
perfectly calibrating with each other
perfectly in tune perfect chemistry
just a performance a symphony an
orchestra
the best social interactions should feel
like wonderful
jazz sessions like emergent
orchestrations
that's magic that's fun
and that's what i want for you for i
want nothing less for you
and i want nothing less for me for this
space
is our common ecstasy